okay I'm not even gonna do a proper
intro for this video because what just
happened that Jujutsu Kaizen is unreal
like I don't know what to say at the end
of the last chapter kusakape literally
declared Gojo to be the winner of the
fight and even though we all knew that
it almost certainly wasn't going to be
that easy what Gage just did to us is
unbelievable I don't know if I've ever
seen such an instant and drastic reverse
Uno in my life but is everything the way
it seems is this really the end of our
boy I know things look really bad and
the entire jjk fandom is absolutely
freaking out on social media a lot of
people are straight up mad about what
just happened but I still have hope that
we are missing something here so let's
get into it you guys know what to do if
you enjoy our jjk content and you want
us to keep it going leave a quick like
to let me know and if you don't know
already we are trying to attain special
grade status here on the channel by
hitting 2 million subscribers
if you're not subscribed already do me a
big favor and subscribe right now
finally this video will of course
contain Jujutsu Kaizen manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned in the previous chapter Gojo
managed to successfully heal his right
arm using reverse curse technique even
though shoko was sure that he wouldn't
be able to heal himself anymore because
he pushed himself too far and he just
didn't have the strength to do it the
narrator even told us that upon healing
his arm Gojo's voltage Rose even further
meaning that he didn't become weaker
rather he was seemingly becoming even
stronger he was actually powering up
towards the end of the chapter Gojo was
able to pull off some brilliant
strategic Maneuvers that allowed him to
merge red and blue to activate Hollow
technique purple he then created a huge
explosion that destroyed a large chunk
of Shinjuku maharaga was destroyed
completely just like agito was destroyed
in the last chapter and Gojo and sukuna
were both serious the injured in the
explosion Gojo was injured because he
was forced to use purple without being
able to properly aim it which is why he
also got caught up in the explosion but
because it was Gojo's own curse
technique that created the explosion in
the first place Gojo was not injured
nearly as badly as tsukuna sukuna lost
the shikigami he lost one of his arms
meaning that he could no longer use his
domain expansion and with all those
other severe injuries that left sukuna
barely standing it looked like the
battle was basically over all the
spectators were suddenly in extremely
good spirits and kusakape went so far as
to officially declare Gojo the winner of
the fight now in my last video I warned
everyone that it was kusakabe who
declared Gojo to be the winner not the
narrator this means that the battle may
not be over yet because unlike the
narrator kusakabe could be mistaken but
even though I issued this warning and
even though I personally didn't think
that the battle was over yet after all
we got all that talk about 2 trump card
a few chapters ago and I don't think
Gage would put that in the story for
nothing I still could not have possibly
anticipated the sheer Madness that gege
hooked up for us in the latest chapter
chapter 236 from the very beginning this
chapter feels completely insane and
surreal and that is especially true when
we contrast the tone and content of this
chapter with the Epic and hopeful ending
of the last chapter like this was just
such a crazy amount of whiplash so let's
break it all down and let's try to come
to terms with what just happened in
Jujutsu Kaizen we start off with suguru
ghetto greeting a somewhat confused
looking Gojo ghetto and Gojo are sitting
in like a large public waiting room
which we later learned is one of those
airport waiting areas Gojo says this is
awful because he always told his
students that when you die you are alone
and yet here he is now with ghetto so
he's hoping that this is all just a part
of his imagination ghetto's just like oh
who cares but Gojo says it matters to
him he then begins to say something
about his father but then he decides not
to continue and says that he left it all
for shoko to handle now this is
definitely frustrating because I don't
know about you guys but I am desperately
curious to find out more about Gojo's
family so to get teased about his father
like this is just mean okay the Gojo
Clan is one of the three most powerful
sorcerer families in the world and yet
we know basically nothing about any of
them except for Gojo but anyway as they
wait at this quote-unquote airport
ghetto asks Gojo how was the king of
curses and Gojo responds that tsukuna
was really strong and what's worse
sukura didn't even have to unleash his
full power kojo doesn't know if he could
have won against sukuna even if sukuna
only had access to his own powers and
wasn't able to use megumi's curse
technique Gojo believes that he gave it
his all during the fight against sukuna
he trained his body he practiced his
technique to Perfection he made full use
of his natural talents he pushed himself
to the Limit and used all of his most
powerful curse techniques and attacks
and yet he still couldn't defeat sukuna
ghetto is surprised that Gojo of all
people would admit this but Gojo says
that the fight was fun and he hopes that
it was a fun challenge for sukuna as
well Gojo then says that he's glad that
he didn't die from old age or disease
but that he died because he was defeated
by a stronger fighter that's when a
young nanami shows up at the airport and
he says that Gojo sounds like an old
Samurai General you hibara is also there
nanami's former classmate who died on a
mission during his first year at Jujutsu
high and he agrees with nanami but he
didn't want to say it out loud Gojo asks
nanami how his own final moments were
Anatomy says that he once asked May
about it and she told him that in his
final moments he should move north if
he's looking for a new side of himself
and he should move South if he wants to
stay who he is nanami chose South
without a second thought and haybara was
also there for him in his final moments
so it wasn't so bad Gojo then says
goodbye to everyone including also
principal Yaga as well as the RICO
amanai and misato kuroi and he prepares
to board the plane it is strongly
implied that satoru Gojo is dead and
that he must now rest in peace back on
the battlefield we see Gojo's body he
has been literally sliced in half sukuna
explains that mahoraga was adapting to
Gojo's Infinity first and it was
changing the cursed energy so that it
could neutralize Infinity itself so once
mahoraga shot that slashing attack
earlier presumably the slash that had
sliced off Gojo's arm it was not
actually the same type of Slash that
sukunai uses even though it looked a lot
like it mahoraga was able to expand the
target of sukuna's curse techniques
attack not just to Gojo but to space
itself
maharaga was able to slash the very
fabric of space Gojo's Infinity which
keeps dividing space over and over again
is powerless against something that just
cuts all that space instantly we'll have
to wait for the official translation in
order to confirm this but it sounds to
me like sukuna was able to learn this
ability to slash the fabric of space
itself from maharaga and he then used
this technique to cut through Gojo's
infinity and basically kill him
off-screen sukuna takes the time to
congratulate Gojo on a well-fought
battle and he says that he will never
forget our boy satoru sukuna then says
don't let me down now as the so-called
Thunder God the Hajime akashimo joins
The Fray kashimo doesn't seem too
bothered by the loss of Gojo he's just
happy to finally have his chance to
fight the strongest Jujutsu sorcerer in
history ryomen sukuna and that is how
this surreal and just unreal chapter
ends seriously how do we go from the end
of the last chapter to this chapter the
amount of whiplash is staggering if you
look online a lot of people are
legitimately mad about what just
happened and they feel that Gojo was
just done extremely dirty by the author
first we're baited into thinking he won
and then the next thing we know he dies
off screen and tsukuna wins it's just so
sudden and unexpected and it's just not
an end befitting a legend like satoru
Gojo well as I said in my last video we
can't assume that Gojo won just because
kusakabe said so and as I'm telling you
in this video we shouldn't buy into the
idea that Gojo is gone forever yes it
does look really really bad but there
are also some hints that suggest that
not everything is as it seems in Gojo's
so-called the last moments he says
goodbye to all of his friends who died
earlier but then he leaves them there at
the airport and moves on unlike say
nanami who Moved South Gojo seems to
move north so to speak looking for a new
side of himself sure that could mean
that he is just passing away peacefully
into the Afterlife following a great
battle against a great opponent but it
could also mean that the overpowered
Gojo is about to really find a new side
of himself that he is about to evolve
Beyond Humanity kind of like Master
tangent he could then return more
powerful than ever before some people
even believe that he might become a
cursed Spirit or something along those
lines but to me the master Tangen root
seems more fitting for Gojo now is what
I'm saying a bit of a stretch I mean
yeah sure but to me the idea that Gojo
just dies here and is gone forever is an
even bigger stretch if that were to
happen then the criticism of this
chapter is definitely fair the issue is
not that Gojo could possibly die because
we all know that he could the issue is
the way it's handled so abruptly and
like off-screen our boy what Gojo
certainly deserves a better send-off
than that it might be impossible for
Gojo to heal his body after such an
injury even after potentially evolving
in some way but as tengen demonstrates
Gojo's body doesn't necessarily have to
resemble that of a human once he evolves
Beyond humanity and after all shoko
thought that he wouldn't be able to heal
his arm either and then he did it very
easily so who knows you cannot put
anything past the Gojo there is also the
option that either sukuna or kenjaku are
planning to take over Gojo's body
meaning that Gojo's body could still be
technically alive but he would not be in
control of it I mean which evil sorcerer
wouldn't want access to Limitless and
the six eyes however with someone like
Gojo you can't underestimate the
possibility that eventually Gojo could
find a way to regain control of his own
body as long as his body remains
technically alive if someone like
kenjaku takes control of Gojo's body I'm
confident that Gojo would eventually
come back it's just a matter of time
finally if Gojo does really die here
like it's over it becomes very difficult
to see where the story goes next unless
Hashima and the others can straight kill
sukuna right now they'll have no hope of
beating him later and that's to say
nothing of kenjaku who is still out
there with Gojo making it clear that
sukuna didn't even use his full power
yet I find it hard to believe that the
others can win without Gojo like our boy
Yuji would need a massive freaking power
up if he's going to become relevant
again unless Yuji seems to have a new
ability to switch bodies in chapter 222
he was seemingly able to swap bodies
with kusakabe imagine if he switched his
own body with Gojo's right before Gojo
died then Yuji would die but Gojo would
continue living within yuji's body now
that would be an insane freaking twist
and it would confirm once and for all
that the real protagonist of Jutsu
Kaizen is satoru Gojo not Yuji itadori
or maybe Yuji can somehow host Gojo's
Soul inside his own body while still
remaining there himself so then they'd
both be the protagonists because they're
sharing one body I don't know Jutsu
cousin is crazy right now what can I say
this was an absolutely shocking chapter
I don't remember the last time I was so
shocked reading a manga chapter please
let me know down in the comments right
now what you thought of this chapter and
what you think is going to happen next
there is no way Gojo is actually dead
right
right if you're looking for more Jujutsu
Kaizen content to watch right now check
out our every special grade sorcerer
ranked and explained link on screen and
in the description if you enjoy our jjk
content and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like right now and
if you want to help us advance to
special grade level on this channel by
hitting 2 million subscribers do me a
big favor and subscribe right now it's
completely free and it helps me out a
lot